the new survey is aiming to improve
levels of public understanding of bowel
cancer
and the importance of early diagnosis
the stay on track survey was
partially set up by former british
athlete chris sakabusi after his
own bowel cancer scare just last year
lucky
that he is with us here now to talk
about it in more detail hi
chris it's great to see you glad to see
you looking so well everything was okay
was it
yeah thank you very much cad hope to
actually see you in person but this is
this this will do
[Laughter]
yeah okay so thank you very much you
know i i'm in great shape
and um i'm really happy to be
involved in this stay on track campaign
with uh norjean and belcast uk you know
it was such a close call
and it was sarah jane me
who really encouraged me with tanya when
i was
actually on sky reviewing the papers not
to be one of those guys
you know the two-thirds of the people
who get the symptoms but
just want to style it out and i've been
starting out for a whole year
when sarah jane said well let's change
that one and when i went to see my
doctor
and i told him about symptoms straight
away colonoscopy
and they found some some polyps that
looked a little bit dodgy
and uh within a week i was having an
operation took out a third of my colon
and um also the polyps and fortunate for
me
it was just before they turned cancerous
and so i got away with it
but i really am here to encourage
especially my age group
you know my demographic men 50s 60s 70s
who were brought up to sort of be tough
and and
style it out you know real men make them
make sure that they're going to be
around for their grandchildren and so
do take care and do something about him
yeah that's fantastic news about sj
she's a smart girl i'm glad that she
talked you into doing that
how important did the doctors tell you
was early diagnosis in treating bowel
cancer
look if you if you get it really really
early you've got a 90 chance in stage
one
of survival if you wait
till it gets to stage four you've got 10
chance i was told even at my early stage
that if i'd waited for another six
months it could have been very very
naughty and i could have been dead
within five years
but i was 60 then that's only i'm 65 in
two and a half years time
the idea that i'm not going to be here
and i'm not laughing anymore
it's quite frightening for me you know
whereas now it looks likely that i could
live like most of us to 75
or 80. um i suppose one of the problems
is that especially men older men find it
embarrassing they just don't want to go
to the doctor i mean
what's the point in dying of ignorance
though
absolutely okay look we've got lots of i
mean
i know we've been through some real
tough times there with with covered 19
and that's given an extra layer of
excuses for us not to go and see our
doctor
um the challenges are though that
potentially a lot of people
who are scared to go to a doctor in 18
months time gonna have some very very
bad news
that could be preventable bowel cancer
is a second biggest killer bowel cancer
is the fourth biggest
cancer but it doesn't need to be as i've
just told you
catch it early you've got a 90 94
chance of survival it really doesn't
make sense and we've got a lot of
highly qualified doctors
sitting there doing this because we are
not going
go and see them look this morning your
doctor
has probably seen please excuse me four
or five bums this morning
they can look at yours too and they're
not going to be faced
that's a very good point well made um
and it's men particularly isn't it who
are embarrassed what is it about
men being embarrassed when they go to
the doctor what's wrong with you guys
[Laughter]
well okay look you think i actually
think you it's a good point here look
i think young ladies are introduced
have in their private areas looked at
very very early
you know they do screening for cervical
cancer when you're in your teens
in your teens men the only people that
look at your part a bit so your mum
and your lovers and you know you just
feel a little bit
awkward but so i would love an idea of
getting
us fellas and maybe my younger brothers
maybe
younger men i i don't know maybe younger
men in the 20s 30s
are much more comfortable you know
letting other people look at them look
look
at them down there but i would like to
see men being introduced to that
experience
like women do much earlier on so that
when you do get to your 40s 50s and 60s
and you do start seeing symptoms you
know blood in your stalls or
changes in your bowel movements you know
or
or or pains in your stomach you're not
too scared
to go and see your doctor you go and do
something about it you don't think
you're hard
and you're tough by not going go and see
your doctor and as a result here you are
larger than life again as usual what are
you doing now what's what's next for you
well i'm studying so i'm just about to
finish my degree as a master of arts
in so in existential coaching so i'm
really excited about that
um more you're going to hear me you're
going to see me in a few tv shows
coming up again you know the odd program
where
it's a game and it's a laugh and i'm
looking forward to some of that and
hopefully
i'm going to be seeing you again kay
live and direct
in your studio simply
cannot wait it's good to talk to you
thanks very much chris
great to see you looking so well thank
you
bless you bless you too thanks very much
indeed so it's our very own sj that
could well have saved his life